kim kardashian and pete davidson's
whirlwind romance is still going strong
absolutely here's the couple smiling big
while exiting a date night in los
angeles
pete and kim getting cozy and holding
hands during the outing kim rocking
black leather leggings and a chic skirt
while pete kept it casual in a baseball
cap and jeans
but that's not all there's also these
snaps of the two laughing out loud and
looking very happy together that's so
cool right if you look close fans think
they've found evidence of what could be
a love bite after spotting what appears
to be a reddish mark on the comedian's
neck that i don't know one thing's for
sure the two have not been shy about
their budding romance since they were
first romantically linked in late
october
a source previously told et that their
relationship is advancing to a quote
deeper level i'm happy to be here those
shots of kim giggling well they're not
exactly surprising we're told quote kim
thinks pete is hysterical and he's
constantly making her laugh really and
we're guessing kim is pretty good at
making pete laugh too the skim's founder
showed off her comedy chops last month
when she made her saturday night live
hosting debut i mean i'm so used to
having 360 million followers watching my
every move i mean how many people watch
snow like 10 million tonight is just a
chill intimate night for me
kim and pete later appeared in a sketch
together and shared this moment of pda
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
we've been seeing a lot of pete and kim
together lately including pete's recent
birthday celebration where the couple
rocked matching pjs and hung out with
kim's mom kris jenner and rapper flavor
flav oh it was amazing
but it all started when pete and kim
were first linked halloween weekend when
the two held hands during a roller
coaster ride at not scary farm and i was
like why not a source tells us that kim
and pete are pretty much inseparable and
very affectionate when they're together
it's so crazy we're looking forward to
more lol and pda moments from this
superstar couple
[Music]